the jurgen experience i remember reading
this story you want to belong nba
referees that would shave points they
were they were really corrupt
yeah the one guy right
guys went to jail yeah didn't they jimmy
you know about all that stuff right
guys went to jail didn't they yes he
sure did yeah
i remember that actually just as you're
saying this was a nfl player today
suspended for a year for betting on nfl
games oh really yeah dirty wait a minute
why can't you bet on a game that you're
in
if you're not in it there's a lot you
could do to manipulate the points when
it's one play that can change the game
well if you're not in it but if you're
not playing no yeah no that's not he's
in the game
your old roommate from
college is is playing
right he can tell you if someone's hurt
yeah you can bet on the game that you're
not in but why can't you bet on a game
that you're in if you're betting to win
like we're gonna [ __ ] them up i'm so
confident i'm gonna bet money i don't
know that that's what was happening
that's pete rose right
no pete rose bet the other way though he
did yeah
pete rose apparently bet the other way
he did which is i love this label that's
in that dope it was banned rather i'll
get you some of those i think he said he
never did i thought he said he did
i thought yeah i thought he didn't bet
against his i thought that was like his
thing like yeah hey i didn't bet against
us i thought so too and then i read an
article oh really uh contrary to popular
belief pete rose bet against his team uh
which is
uh
which means
so barry bonds is never gonna be that
might not be true yeah no i'm actually
looking like that with this player too
it says a league investigation uncovered
no evidence indicating any inside
information was used or that any game
was compromised in any way so there was
no evidence suggesting any awareness by
coach's staff teammates or any other
players of his betting activity it took
place during a five-day period in late
november while he was away from the team
and away from the club's facility on the
non-football illness list and he was
betting for his team i don't i don't i
honestly don't know that part now it
doesn't say find out if pete rose bet
against his team because i i if not
we're gonna have to edit that out i
don't want pete rose to be mad at me
yeah
if i'm wrong i mean i could be wrong i
do remember reading that but yeah the
thing is i've read [ __ ] about me that's
not true so maybe
writing things about him that's not true
yeah even the thing we're about to look
up might not yeah so he
said in the book he never bet against
the reds right
but i thought so he was making bets i
believe in a way that maybe he had uh he
was managing the team so he could have
done things to manipulate stuff like by
playing a player to win the game real
hard tonight [ __ ] up tomorrow's game
uh-huh playing a picture to get to
but did he oh oh i see i see so he
[ __ ] the team
by betting
so he
he didn't make strategically wise
decisions because he was trying to cover
a point spread and that's probably why
he got in trouble whether or not that
actually happened or was speculation i
think that's where i'm like i don't know
i wasn't even alive then well that's why
betting that's why betting on it all
these questions come up that's why you
can't do it would you just look up pete
rose actually did bet against his team i
i look some i'm 100 looking
quotes from p rose quote patrick's show
i bet on my team every night i didn't
bet on my team four nights a week
i bet on my team to win every night
because i loved my team i believed in my
team i did everything in my power every
night to win that game
so the
story that i read that said that he
didn't bet on his team that he bet
against his team that's horseshit
probably but that's pretty cool i don't
know yeah people don't i don't think
they believe him because they would say
of course you're saying yeah right
according to him the problem is i don't
know how many gambling junkies you've
ever met do you know any not really i've
known quite a few that have have real
problems and those [ __ ] will
come up with
any reason at all to gamble
and they get they're sick it's like it's
like do you remember when kitty dukakis
was drinking aftershave
[ __ ] yeah yeah she was so sick she was
like she was alcoholic and she was so
sick that she was drinking like whatever
she could find yeah that's the thing
with the gamblers do you think there's
it's a sickness do you think that that
how do you feel about gambling being now
available to everybody all over the
country
i think
people need lessons and how to manage
their thought process
and i think gambling is exciting and
it's uh like when i was in vegas a few
months ago with uh whitney cummings
here's probably rose did not bet on the
reds to win
in the four games here it is the four
that rose didn't bet on the reds were
all started by bill gullickson the
problem comes when you realize this if
he bet the reds to win every night when
the four knights he didn't bet on the
reds would send up a gigantic red flag
the gamblers would know that rose wasn't
betting on the reds so this may be the
right time to bet against them you might
say rose was still trying to win those
games and yes maybe he was but if you
take a closer look at the games in
question it becomes even more disturbing
and they break down each of these games
in question
so he might have bet against his team
it's too many questions
it's just too much you know just even by
not betting maybe he's paying back a
debt to somebody he owed money to and
i'll not bet here but you can right your
money right right you can make money
here